A prophet will not be killed outside
Jerusalem. And then the Muslim says,
"Well, Jesus was killed on Calvary." I'm
not sure about the geographical area
about where No, I've already answered
this
thoroughly. Go to Luke 13. I know what
he's referring to. Luke 13, right? He's
mentioning Luther. Let me get you the
article on I wrote an article on this,
guys. Uh, repeat the objection. I won't
cut you off. Just repeat the objection,
but let me go get the article because I
wrote one on it.
So there's a verse in the Bible in Luke
13:33 and Jesus says that, you know, a
prophet won't be killed outside of
Jerusalem, but Jesus, I'm not sure the
100%. Yeah, he was he was he was he was
crucified outside the city wall on a
Jesus was crucified outside the city
wall. And Muslims like to say that
because Jesus wasn't crucified in
Jerusalem, either he wasn't a prophet or
he wasn't crucified. Yep. Here's the
article on this guys. Here's the
article. See, glory to Jesus Christ
because I've heard all these arguments.
We've written articles on it. Here's the
article. Lord, I'll put in description
box comment section. I'm going to give
you I'm going to give you the link.
Okay. So, you guys heard the objection.
Read Luke 13:33 for us, sister.
Could you send the the article cuz it's
I'm not on the YouTube. I just gave it
to you. No, I gave it to you. Okay. So,
just read the the verse if you can. In
any case, I must press on today and
tomorrow and the next day, for surely no
prophet can die outside Jerusalem. Okay.
So, you see Jesus died outside
Jerusalem. He was beaten in the city,
taken out of the city. Contradiction.
Haha. Right.
Okay. Now, how do we respond to this?
You guys ready for the response?
Yes. Okay. Now, go to Luke 13, same
chapter. Now, I want you to start
reading from 31 to 35. Guys, pay
attention. Luke
13:31-35. Pay attention now because
we're now going to show the Muslims.
They're desperate, more desperate than
Muhammad. Okay? Luke 13:31-35. Let's
read it. Okay? Jesus's sorrow for
Jerusalem. At that time, some Pharisees
came to Jesus and said to him, "Leave
this place and go somewhere else. Herod
wants to kill you." He replied, "Go tell
that fox. I will keep on driving out
demons and healing people today and
tomorrow and on the third day I will
reach my goal. In any case, I must press
on and today and tomorrow and the next
day for surely no prophet will die
outside Jerusalem." Yeah. Just read it
slowly so you understand what you're
reading. Not too fast because in the
debates you got to be fast but slow
enough to get the point. Okay. So now
keep reading to 35.
Jerusalem. Jerusalem. You who kill the
prophets and stone those sent to you.
How often I have longed to gather your
children together as a hen gathers her
chicks under her wings and you are not
willing. Look, your house is left to you
desolate. I tell you, you will not see
me again until you say, "Blessed is he
who comes in the name of the Lord." Now,
let me ask you a question. When he says,
"Jerusalem, Jerusalem, you who have
killed the prophets," who is he
referring to? Who killed the prophets?
The city, the dirt that they walked on,
or the people? The the people. They
killed the the former prophets before
Christ. So when he says Jerusalem,
Jerusalem, is he referring to an
inanimate city or is he using Jerusalem
to refer to the leaders of Jerusalem? Uh
the leaders the leaders. So the meaning
in the context is no prophet can be
killed outside of Jerusalem. Meaning
that he has to go to the Jewish re
leaders and be condemned by them. That's
what Jerusalem means in the context.
Wow. Okay. That makes so much sense.
Okay. So So what's Jerusalem in the
context?
It's the the leaders of the the temple
or the Pharisees of the city, the Jewish
people, the leaders of the city. So when
he says no prophet can be killed outside
of Jerusalem means no prophet can be
condemned apart from the
Jewish
religious leaders establishment.
Are you seeing that? Because again
that's not my interpretation. It's not
my interpretation. How did you find
Jerusalem? Right in the verses after 33.
Now read 335 so it can sink in.
Okay. In any case, I must press on today
and tomorrow and the next day. For
surely no prophet can die outside
Jerusalem. Then he calls out Jerusalem.
Jerusalem, Jerusalem, you who kill the
prophets and stone those. Now you make
the connection. No prophet can be killed
outside of Jerusalem. Oh Jerusalem, you
who kill the prophets. I see that. I see
it very clearly. So who who is Jerusalem
that's going to kill Jesus? like he,
she, it killed the prophets, the people,
the city, the leaders of the city, the
leaders. So, it's not talking about I
have to be killed in the city. I have to
be killed by the religious establishment
in Jerusalem, which is exactly what
happened, right? Mhm. Okay. Now, let me
give you further proof that Jesus is not
saying they won't kill me outside the
city. He's saying Jerusalem as the
religious establishment, the leaders,
the religious authorities that govern
Jerusalem, they will condemn me to to
death. They will kill me. Has nothing to
do with me not dying outside the city.
The same Jesus goes on to give the
parable of the tenants. Right? Mhm. Go
to Luke 20 13- 15. Then the owner of the
vineyard said, "What shall I do? I will
send my son whom I love. Perhaps they
will respect him." But when the tenants
saw him, they talked the matter over.
This is their heir. They said, "Let's
kill him, and the inheritance will be
ours." So they they they threw him out
the vineard. Wait, the vineard is
Jerusalem. Yeah. So when did they kill
him? When they threw him out of the
vineard vineyard. Yeah. And killed him.
They th Okay. So where was Jesus killed?
Outside of the outside of Jerusalem. So
where's the contradiction? There is
none. Just a misunderstand. Well, not
misunderstanding, just blatant. Yeah,
it's all in my article, by the way.